hi I'm Erik Bosse and the vengers
in-game gave a heartbreaking send-off to
Iron Man Tony Stark but did so in a way
that was true to all aspects of his
character including how freakin smart
the guy is making all of us feel like
Ruffalo's Bruce banners Ruffalo's in in
game Tony Stark not only configures the
missing link of the other Avengers time
travel technology he proves to have the
sharpest recollection when it comes to
details within historical timelines
on-the-spot he were calls a backup time
and place to retrieve the tesseract and
more Pym particles but even more
ingeniously he uses tiny details within
past generations of his own Iron Man
armor specific forgotten loopholes
within upgrades as a weakness that he
exploits against their past selves in
order to get the upper hand really the
entire endgame film is a tribute to how
brilliant Tony Stark has been when it
comes to adapting his tech battle after
battle over the past decade and I'm
gonna break down all these hidden genes
okay so when Yuri watch in game and all
of the MCU movies with Iron Man you
start to notice specific things about
the evolution of Tony Stark's suit in
each movie stark adapts the technology
in small ways to respond to mistakes
from previous conflicts we witness this
adaptive thinking in the first Ironman
Tony's trial and error montage as he
customized each component of his armor
but that experimentation actually never
stopped it evolved all the way through
the present so when the first Iron Man
Tony was kidnapped in Afghanistan with
no GPS for anyone to track his location
so later in Spider Man homecoming stark
reveals to Peter that the suit he
designed for him comes with a GPS
tracker how did you find me did you put
track on my suit or something I put
everything in your suit including this
heater actually that heater was an
adaptation from Starks past experience
as well when he iced up during his test
flight in the first Ironman and an Iron
Man 3 when his suit lost power in the
snow in the middle of Tennessee
ah that's brisk you could also see that
parachute that popped out of Peter
Parker's suit is an adaptation from
Rody's war machine armor and civil war
which was months prior it dropped out of
and nearly killed rody but more on the
lessons learned from rody later one of
the more memorable moments in the first
Avengers movie was when Ironman thought
Thor and Thor's lightning accidentally
supercharge Tony's suits powerful
hundred percent capacity how about that
remember the previous time we had seen
an Iron Man he was fighting whiplash in
Iron Man 2 and that previous generation
of armor was particularly vulnerable to
electrical damage but of course the
biggest vulnerability to Stark's
early-generation armor was his arc
reactor in his chest he had that reactor
surgically removed at the end of Iron
Man 3 chucked it into the ocean
probably plugged the whales blowhole
with it but earlier his mechanical heart
was a major weak point especially when
Obadiah Stane the bigger Lebowski of the
MCU paralyzed Tony yanked it out of his
chest
and that brings us to Tony's brilliance
and the time heist and end game see Tony
knew that the 2012 generation the mark 7
armor was still powered by a flesh
embedded arc reactor something that if
tampered with can cause him to go into
cardiac arrest
stark also knew from his experience in
civil war that the tiny openings between
the pieces of his armor were wide enough
for ant-man to shrink down into without
being noticed
of course Start fixed that flaw with
nanotech armor revealed an infinity war
tiny BOTS that lock into place
seamlessly without any cracks for little
little things to slip through
but back in 2012 this was still a
vulnerability so present-day stark uses
these old design flaws the gaps in his
armor and the fragility of his old Stark
reactor to allow ant-man to paralyze his
old self so they can snatch a tesseract
but Stark also knows that this mark 7
suit won't get damaged by an electro
shock from mill near so a little love
tap from Thor could bring him back to
life this adaptation with Starks armor
continued and other interesting ways
throughout endgame but before I get to
that thank you to honey for sponsoring
this episode honey is a free browser
extension to save you money when you
shop online when you buy anything if
you're not actively shopping around for
the best deal you're probably not gonna
save that much money but honey takes
care of that for you while you shop
online honey scans the internet for
coupon codes and other
counts and then automatically applies
the coupon with the biggest savings to
your cart and checkout it's like magic
I used honey when I bought a couple
pizzas from Papa John's online I was
thrilled to save $8 sixty-eight cents
made me feel less bad about eating
several pizzas alone honey works on over
20,000 sites like Amazon eBay Game Stop
Best Buy and more and it takes zero
effort to install it's just two clicks
by going to join honey calm slash new
rock stars but he is for everyone
because it works for practically
anything you buy online and like I said
that's easy only takes two clicks to
install ten million people are already
saving with honey with over 100,000
five-star reviews on the google chrome
store it's basically free money
according to Time magazine and according
to me look there's really no reason not
to start using honey today it's free to
use and easy to install on computer with
just two clicks so shop with confidence
kid honey for free at join honeycomb
slash new rock stars again that's join
honey calm slash new rockstars honey the
smart shopping assistant it saves you
time and money and thanks again honey
for sponsoring this episode okay back to
the subtle ways stark adapted his armor
over the generations in age of Ultron
there were two big upgrades the iron
Legion which led to Ultron and
ultimately division which was the first
derivation of stark tech that could
contain an infinity stone the second one
was of course mark 44 the Hulkbuster
armor and age of Ultron the Hulkbuster
repulsor blasts weren't powerful enough
to restrain the Hulk so when a bidding
war starts new mark 50 armor features
backup boosters to blast cull obsidian
at the black order who has a similar
build to Hulk the mark 50 armor is
awesome it has these new flight
stabilizers shown during Iron Man's
fight against Thanos on Titan to control
his flight during combat which is
something he had trouble with before it
also has a rocket booster on his feet
which allows them super flight speed so
he could catch up to Peter on the cue
ship he installed that after he failed
to catch up to row D during Rody's fall
in civil war also in civil war when he
lost against cap and Bucky during their
melee at the end of the movie an
infinity war the mark 50 armor features
new melee weapons which stark uses
against Thanos now one of those melee
weapons in infinity war was a shield the
shield is formed out of starts and an
attack pieces but the blast from
Thanos's power stone ward
those nanobots causing the nanobots on
the rest of Starks armor to relocate and
weaken so stark adapted this for his
latest mark 85 armor an endgame which
features new external energy shields he
fires these up to brace for the impact
blast from Hulk snappy in his stark
gauntlet and that gauntlet it Starks
most critical tech adaptation and
endgame back in age of Ultron start
learned that an Android body derived
from Ultron iron Legion Tech could house
an infinity stone to of course make
vision and now Stark has expanded on
that foundation to recreate Thanos's
Infinity Gauntlet as a unit of his own
design but this stark gauntlet features
a key feature nanotech infinity war
showed how those nanobots can morph
reconfigure into new shapes there's
actually a very subtle visual detail
where Stark took off his sunglasses and
they absorbed into its nanotech armor as
it assembled around him sunglasses were
also nanotech if you think about it
Stark didn't need to take him off at all
he just kind of took him off to look
badass for an ebony mom this absorption
function gives Stark his key move over
Thanos at the end of the film Stark was
unable to claw the gauntlet and the
stones off Thanos's hand during the
brawl on Titan and he was so damn close
dude that must have driven him nuts over
the years so with his new start gauntlet
the nanotech allows his armor to absorb
the stones back onto his own hand in the
end Starks powerful sacrifice was such
an emotional gut punch because we know
he achieved it by finally perfecting the
armor that he had been tinkering with
year after year he's the ultimate weapon
builder finally crafting the ultimate
peacekeeping tool this story arc is
memorialized with Starks first arc
reactor framed by pepper and placed on
his funeral wreaths and if he stuck
around through the credits of endgame
the sound of Tony hammering in the cave
echoes once more to remind us that Tony
Stark's obsession with constant
innovation and adaptation is what made
this engineer the ultimate MCU hero
comment down below with your favorite
Iron Man upgrade over the years and
follow me on instagram and twitter at EA
boss and if you live in the LA area come
check out my live monthly comedy show
darkest timeline
Friday June 7th ticket link in the
description below and subscribe to new
rockstars and subscribe to our Inside
Marvel podcast fever early access to all
of our Marvel breakdowns thank you for
joining me and see you next time fellow
blows